hello everyone thanks for joining me
today
my name is Poisson bracket I work as a
senior consultant with redefine this is
my twitter handle and my plug if you'd
like to follow me today we're going to
talk about kubernetes and our agenda for
today would be talking about what is
coupon it is and why we should care
about it and then we will have a
walkthrough of the Copernicus
architecture and after that we will see
how would we leverage the Copernicus
building blocks in order to deploy a
typical asp.net application that
communicates with the sequel server
database on top of it so let's start
with having a shared understanding about
containers but before we do that how
many of you have used containers already
oh wow that's almost everyone that's
great so historically we used to deploy
our applications on top of physical
machines and in order to make a better
utilization of the hardware we were
deploying multiple applications on the
same machine and that meant that the
applications as well as their
dependencies were entangled with each
other as well as with the host operating
system which you didn't provide us with
a good isolation between the
applications and that brought us into
the virtual machines which provided us
with better isolations when we were
using one application per virtual
machine but it was very heavy weight
because it's hardware virtualization and
that led us into the containers
technology and the containers is
basically providing us with a standard
way to package the application its
dependencies runtime and configurations
in a standard package and then we could
provide this package into a container
engine and that container engine could
spin up multiple containers based on
that package containers provided us with
the same benefits that we had from birth
with the virtual machines from isolation
perspective so containers cannot access
each other but it also it's more
lightweight so we can move the exact
same package across different
environments and the reason behind that
is containers is using operating
system-level virtualization and there
are multiple container engines in the
market but the most used one is docker
and docker is a platform that allows us
to develop and run applications using
the container technology and thanks to
the container technology we could
package any kind of application in a
container regardless of its language or
run time so you could package
applications written in node JavaScript
go a speed net or any other language and
once we package our application we could
deploy this application into a
production environment that has docker
engine running on top of it and if we
are lucky our application will start go
viral and a lot of users will start
consuming it but in a container based
environment this will start bringing
more challenges such as how could we
scale our application automatically to
address the load that's coming to it or
how would we have some sort of
self-healing features so if the
container died we spin up another one to
replace the one that just died how could
we have some sort of highly available
environment so if the host that is
hosting our containers died we scheduled
those containers on another host in
order to run the same containers our
application might keep growing to a
certain extent that we decided to split
it into a set of micro services which
will start bringing more challenges such
as how the services communicate with
with each other we need to have some
sort of service discovery between those
services and all those challenges in a
container based environment are usually
resolved with using a container
orchestration platform and container
extraction plasmids allows us to manage
containers at scale so there are a lot
of features that comes out of the box
with the container observation platform
such as service discovery scaling
horizontal health monitoring failover
networking and there are multiple
container orchestration platforms
available in the market but the one that
we're gonna keep talking about today is
kubernetes
and the copernicus is an open source
container orchestration platform that
allows us to automate the process of
deploying scaling and managing
containerized applications and bonita
springs in addition to the features that
comes with any container orchestration
platform is more features such as a
self-healing horizontal scaling of the
nodes that are hosting our application
and to our applications themselves or
the containers it also brings automated
rollout and rollback secret and
configuration management storage
orchestration and
heaps of other features so let me walk
you through a very high-level overview
of the Copernicus architecture in a
kubernetes cluster consists of two types
of nodes the first type of node is the
master node and the master node is the
one responsible for managing your
cluster and this is the entry point to
to run anything on a hypnotist cluster
and the worker node the worker node is
actually where your container actually
run and let's let's assume we have
packages application and we wanted to
deploy this container on top of
Copernicus and let's see what are the
key components that live inside our
architecture or our nodes that gets
involved in that the entry point to any
keep on each cluster is a component
living on the master node called API
server and the responsibility of the API
server is exposing set of api's to be
consumed by any client and any client
such as the coupon et CLI which is cubes
ETL or the UI dashboard or any other
client that could make a call to those
api's so we one of those clients will
send a request to the kunis cluster to
say or to the API server we would like
to run that container on top of the
cluster the API server will validate the
request process it and we'll save that
request into a database and that
database is etcd database and etcd is
basically a distributed key-value store
that is used by kubernetes to maintain
its cluster state once we save the state
into the database
another component comes into play which
is the scheduler and the responsibility
of the scheduler to find the best worker
node to host your container and it takes
into consideration stuff like there is
the hardware requirements for your
container and once it finds that node it
just updates the state in the database
through the API server nothing has been
scheduled yet then another component
comes into play which is the couplet and
the couplet is a component that runs on
each worker node and it's responsibility
is to keep watching the API server to
find if there is any work to be
scheduled on that worker and it will
find that there is a container to be
scheduled and and at that point it makes
a call to another
component living in the water which is
the container and time and there are
multiple container and times such as
docker or rocket or there are other
containers that satisfy the container
and time requirements and the container
and time is the one that actually spin
up your container so at this point this
lose all those are the main components
in required to run your container but
there is one more key component that I'd
like to make sure that you are aware of
on the Kunis cluster which is the
controller manager and you can think of
the controller manager as infinite loop
that is running all the time and the
responsibilities of the controller
manager is to keep monitoring the
cluster so and keep comparing the
current state of the cluster versus a
desired state of the cluster so as an
example if we request it to run two
instances of a concerting container and
the country a controller manager found
that the current number of the
containers is one it will make some
corrective actions to make the current
number of containers to be two and those
are the key components that everyone
should be aware of while you are working
with a keeper Nittis architecture now
that you know Copernicus you might be
interested in trying this on your
machine or any other environment and
there are multiple ways to start working
with coupon IDs the first one is running
it on a local host and you could use
mini cube or docker for desktop so if
you already have docker installed there
is one a check box once you take it you
will have a coupon in this cluster
running on your machine you can run it
could run coupon it is on-premises
either on a virtual machine or a
hardware physical machine you could also
use any of the cloud offerings that such
as Google AWS or Azure which provides
you with a platform as a service
offerings as well
and once you have a Kunis cluster you
could deploy your container eyes the
application on top of it
so I'd like to spend the rest of the
talk showing you how do we actually
deploy a typical aerated application
communicating with a sequel server
database on top of it then how would we
scale our application so we have
multiple instances of the same
application with the load balancer
sitting on top of it to be used by the
clients and that application will be
communicating with a highly available
sequel server database so
let me show you the application and the
purpose today is not to actually build
the application but will show we'll see
how would we take the already built
application on to the journey of running
it on top of the cluster so it's a
typical tasks list application it's
built with asp.net core and it has like
home about contact and tasks and tasks
is basically having a crud operations
for a task list and I'm using entity
framework code to communicate with a
sequel server database so just I can add
another task and this is providing us
with the typical like add delete mark as
completed so the first step in order to
deploy our application on the cluster is
to continue eyes this application to
build that package once we containerize
it we have to provide it to configure it
in a way or package in a way that could
be understood by Copernicus cluster and
that is the pod pods are basically the
atomic unit of scheduling inside
kubernetes
our application container will always
live inside a pod it will never be
outside a pot and the pot could contain
multiple containers living inside of it
and those containers could communicate
seamlessly because they share the same
network namespace in addition to that
the pod itself could have volumes and
volume is basically a data directory and
we'll talk about the details of the
volumes later on and that volume could
be consumed by the containers living
inside that pod and pods usually
represents a single instance of an
application which means if we would like
to scale our application we will deploy
more pods as opposed of deploying more
containers inside the same pod so let's
see how would we actually package our
application deploy it as a pod on top of
cabinets so here is our application in
Visual Studio
it's a typical edge with net core
application this is our tasks container
it's using entity framework context to
communicate with the sequel server
database so the first step as I said is
to containerize it and we could add a
container support for our application or
at a docker file using the built-in
feature of Visual Studio
of AD Duker support and once you add the
cur support this will create a docker
file for you or you could write a docker
file from scratch so let me show you the
docker file everyone can see at the back
good so here's our local file this is
the one that just comes out of the books
with the ace witness template what we
have here is basically the instructions
to package our application the first
step is defining the port that this
application will be receiving the
requests on top of it then we have the
first step is nougat package restore
then we are copying the rest of the
application file and the next step is
building and publishing the application
and finally we are defining what is the
entry point of our application so each
time we run a container this command
will be the command that will get
executed inside that container
now we package it now we created our
docker file the next step is to create
an image so this is just a plain text
file we did it actually create the image
so far and in order to create an image
we can use ray we can use a docker
command docker build and provide the
image name and then we provide the build
context which is if our docker file have
any passes it will depend on that
context file and on the context that we
provide once we do this all the
instructions in that we have inside the
docker file will be executed and it will
provide us with an image I have already
done that so we don't have to see the
whole weight for the whole build image
to complete so I have created a couple
of images based on that application and
they are called Sambora card / task list
as you can see I have already built two
images for our application and those are
the ones that we can use to deploy to
our Copernicus cluster we can run that
container on top or that image on top of
Copernicus in two ways the first one is
the imperative way and the imperative
way is basically using the cube City L
which is a coupon it is client provide
it with a command run then we provide
the image name and this will run a pod
or run our container on top of the
cluster and the other way is the
declarative way and this is actually the
one that we're gonna use today and the
declarative way is basically building a
ml fire or JSON file and that e ml file
we could provide it in to our cube CTL
and keep CTL make the relative call to
the API server inside the cube R in this
cluster so let's see the ml file or our
pod definition
generally any kubernetes object require
four parameters the first one is the
kind of the object that we would like to
create second one is the API version and
as I said the key entry point to the
cluster is the API server and this is
basically telling the QTL which API
version that we would like to talk to
and based on that version the spec
section which is like the body of your
request could be different based on that
version we have another object another
attribute which is the metadata and in
this case we are just providing the name
of the pod then the spec section the
spec section is like the body for our
pod we could have multiple containers
living inside of it but in this case we
only have one container which is the
asp.net application so we provide the
container name we provide the image that
we have built and the image pool policy
this is basically telling keepin it is
to use the image that I have already
have built or grabbed on my local
machine and this is just to save few
months in our demo the last bit is the
port that this container is exposing and
this is the same port that we have in
our docker file with that object created
we can use cube CTL
and provide it with a command apply
provide the file and we can see that
there is a pod created communities
provide us with another key component
which is a coupon it is dashboard which
is a UI that allows us to explore the
objects that have been deployed on top
of coupon it is so if we switch to the
kubernetes dashboard we can see there is
a section for the pods and we have our
pod has been created already and we can
see the details of the containers living
inside that pod so our container will be
the tasks app and the image that is used
in inside that container and I can't
connect to my application to verify that
it's actually running using a feature in
communities which is port forward so
I'll use cube CTL port forward provide
the pod name and the hook the host port
and the port that I will be targeting
and this will build a tunnel between my
host machine and the pod once we run
that I will open a new tab and let's try
there you go our application is already
running so so far we managed it to
deploy our application as a pot on top
of Keeper nice but what happened if that
pod dies for any reason if the pod dies
Copernicus will not automatically spin
up another another pod for us it doesn't
provide the self-healing feature
out-of-the-box for the pod but we could
leverage another object in communities
which is called replica set and the
replica set is providing us with this
feature to tell coupon it is to maintain
a certain number of replicas from a pod
and this means if the pod dies another
one will be spend up automatically and
so if we assume that we have a scenario
that we would like to maintain two
instances of an engine X container and
the first time when we deploy our
replica set communities will go and
create two pods on the workers that we
have but if anything went wrong with any
of the pods like for a worker failure
queue penitas will automatically
discover that there is
the number of the pods are less than the
desired and it will automatically spin
up a new pod on one of the healthy nodes
and this is happening thanks to those
like infinite loops that are running on
the kubernetes master and the way the
replica set connects to the pod is using
another feature in kubernetes which is
labels and labels providing us with a
set of key values that could be assigned
to a pod a replica set or any other
object on copernicus so we deploy our
replica set to coupon it is telling it
please maintain a certain number of pods
that have that label or multiple labels
so let's see how would we switch our pod
to be controlled by a replica set and
see those self-healing features in
action first of all I will stop this
will clean these deployments we can
create our replica see here is the
replica set object definition again the
same four parameters the kind of the
object is replica set the API version
and as you can see the version that we
are using for the replica set is
different from the version that we are
using for the pod and that's fine
because each API could has its own
different versions and then the name of
the replica set that we are using then
the spec definition and inside the spec
we have the number of replicas that we
would like to maintain of that pod then
we define the selector this is where we
define the label that we will be using
to find out the pods and in here we are
using match labels we will try to find
the pods with the label that has the key
app and the value tasks app the next
part is template and template is
basically the pod definition which is
more or less what we had in the last
file of the pod object definition the
only difference here is the label
dissection that we have added to the
template section which means any pod
that will be scheduled based on that
replica set will have that label and
this is the same label that we are using
in the label selector for the replica
set so let's apply or deploy this
replica set
again using the same command the cube
city L apply will provide the file name
and this will create our replication
switching back to the dashboard we have
we can go and inspect the replica set
section and we can see that our replica
set has been created and inside that
replica set we have three pods and each
pod is pasted on it has the same
container that we had in the last demo
with the same image name that we have
defined the only difference is that
label section it has the label that we
have added to the template definition
and if I grab this pot I can connect to
it using the same port forward similar
to the last time we provide a different
port just to make it to make sure that
we are connecting to the right
application you need to change this port
as well and there you go the application
is running with the replica set which is
more or less what we had in the last
demo but the difference now is if we
decided to go to the replica set and if
any of those pot dies and I can do this
by just actually deleting one of those
spots another one will be automatically
scheduled for this replica set because
the cue list cluster who found that the
number of pods is less than the desired
and it will automatically spin that new
pod and if I keep deleting communities
will keep creating another pod and one
of the good things with the replica set
is we can scale the number of replicas
that we are monitoring just with an ad
hoc command from the cube CTL or using
that scale in the dashboard so right now
we are only having three pods we could
scale this to be six or seven or any
number that we would like to so on its
six seven this is going to create
automatically the pods and again if any
of those pods died Japanese will
automatically spin up another pod to
replace it so this is how would we
deploy our pod and have some sort of
self-healing using a replica set but
usually after we after the first version
is rolled out who would like to deploy a
new version of our app
vacation and usually you would like to
do this with minimal downtime and
hopefully we'll have some safety
mechanism so if something goes wrong
with our deployment which shouldn't
happen we would roll back to the old
version of the application and in order
to give the loose kind of features we
need to use another object to control
our replica set and that object is a
deployment object and the deployment
object allows us to have those sort of
roll out and roll back features for our
replica set so the first time we deploy
our application a replica set will be
created with the pods living inside of
it but the key features with the
deployment is if we decided to roll out
a new version of our application and
this would usually happen by building a
new image and providing the new image
name to the deployment object behind the
scene capabilities will go and spin up a
new replica set and then it will start
spinning up a new pod inside the replica
set using the new image and then it will
kill another pod in the old replica set
and it will keep doing this process till
all the desired pods are created in the
new replica set and all the old pods are
deleted from the or all killed in the
old replica set and if something at that
point the deployment will be pointing or
monitoring the the new replica set and
if something went wrong so if we found
the bug in the new release we could
easily roll back to the old replica set
and the same process that happened with
the rollout will happen with the
rollback so let's see how would we use a
deployment object in order to roll out
and a normal replica set then we will
update it or roll out a new version of
our application let me stop this and
clean the deployment here's our object
definition again the kind is deployment
the API version that we are using and
the name of the deployment object and
the rest of this file is more or less
exactly the same that we have in the
replica set there are other parameters
that we could provide to the deployment
object such as the rollout strategy
which is basically controlling how many
pods should be created while we are
rolling out versus how many pose that
should be killed in the old replicas it
but for the sake of this demo I'll keep
it simple I will not provide any extra
parameters and let's see how would we
actually deploy this again it's one
command it's Q city L apply provide the
file name and this will create our
deployment switching back to the
dashboard we can see that the deployment
object has been created and inside that
deployment is a replica set and inside
the replica set are the pods I would
like to take a note of that replica set
so we can compare sorry so we can't
compare with with the new replica set
when we roll out a new version of our
application and again if I connect it to
any of those pods we should be able to
view the application running values port
forward provide the pod name and
different port again to make sure that
we are yes I'm in port forwards and
change the port here here is our
application running again as you might
have noticed the tasks tab will not be
working right now because we actually
didn't deploy the sequel application yet
but we will do this in few minutes so we
have deployed our application and we
have seen the deployment object has been
created but right now I would like to
roll out a new version of that
application and we do this by changing
the image name so I have already created
a new image and that image has the tag
v2 or the name v2 and when we roll out
this version our application should have
v2 shown beside the tasks list so let's
hourly update our deployment I'll just
call the same command and then let's
switch back to the dashboard to see what
happened here is our deployment and
still running and now it's done a new
replica set has binky
and we know this because we have taken a
note of the old replica set and as you
can see the name of the replica set is
different from the old replica set and
the new replica set has new pots living
inside of it and those pots are pasted
on the new image name that we have
provided in our object definition so if
I connect it to that pot right now I
should be able to see the v-2 happening
in the homepage on a different pot if we
refresh the homepage right now we should
see v2 which is great but the the
greatest thing is to see how this
process happen behind the scene and I'd
like to show this using a command in
Cuban it is called describe and the
describe command could be used with any
object that we have in Cuba needs to see
the details of that object and as a part
of that we can see the events that
happened on that object lifecycle let me
create clear that cube city el describe
I'd like to know the details of the
tasks deployment and this will show us
the template definition of the pod the
containers that are living inside of it
and this is a roll out roll running
updated strategy and we can't change
those parameters but the same section
that I wanted to make sure that you see
here is the events section so when we
first deployed our application it was
created a new replica set and that
replica set is the one that we have
taken a note of it here and the scale
did this this replica said to three
immediately but then we request it to
roll out a new version of our
application and what happened is a new
replica set was created but it scaled
only to one and then the old replica set
was a scale to two and again the new
replica set scale to - the old replica
set scaled to 1 so this is the process
of creating and killing the pods inside
the replica set till the older pods in
the knee
new replica set were created so the
desired replicas became free and the old
replicas become zero and we can see the
revisions so the more we do more
deployments or updates to our deployment
object we can see all those revisions
using a command called cube CTL roll-out
history of a certain deployment as you
can see right now we have two revisions
the more we deploy them all we have
revisions and with the deployment we
could roll back from the current
revision to the old revision and we can
do this using the undo command so let's
do that so I'll try to roll back from
the current version to the old version
you roll out undo deployment tasks
deployment this is the deployment name
and right now if we go to the dashboard
we can see that the deployment object is
being updated and we can see here that
this deployment has been updated to use
the same image but what I wanted to show
you here is this replica set is exactly
the same replica set that we had when we
first deployed our deployment object so
this is how would we get those kind of
safety mechanisms with automated rollout
and rollback of our application and we
can do the same thing with our sacred
application we can create a deployment
object and that deployment object will
have a pod and that pod will be our
sequel application but we will be
missing something which is how would the
asp.net pod connect to our database pod
we could start by grabbing the database
pod IP and provide it to the ASP is it
pod maybe through an environment
variable but pods genera are ephemeral
which means they could die for any
reason and if the database pod died
another one will peace pinned up
automatically thanks to the replica set
and the new pod will have a new IP and
is going to Prague the connectivity
between the asp.net pod and the database
pod and to avoid this situation we could
use another object in Copernicus which
is services and services allows us to
logically group set of pods using a
label selector similar to the one that
we used with the replica set but in
addition to that it also provided
provides us with a dns name that could
be used by the consumers so in our
scenario you could have a service that
is pointing to the database pod using a
label selector and our asp.net pod could
use the service dns name to consume that
database port which means if something
went wrong with our database pod for any
reason the a speed node pod doesn't have
to keep a track of the IPS of the
database pod and this means that our
application will be looking like that we
have a service and the service will be
pointing to the asp.net pods the asp.net
pods will be using the DNS name of the
database pod and that service will will
keep track of the database port and in
addition to just being logically
grouping the pods and providing us with
a DNS name services also provides us
with some sort of load balancing
features so when we put the service in
front of the asp.net pods the requests
that are coming to our application will
be load balancing across the running
pods so let's see how would we update
our application to deploy our sacred
application then connect the asp.net pod
to the database pod
I'm going to clean deployment and why we
are doing this let me show you the
object definition so this is the same
deployment object that we had in the
last demo the only difference we have
here is the environment variable that I
have provided and this is basically the
connection string that our a spinet pod
R is going to use and the key thing that
you I'd like you to note here is the
name of the server and this is basically
the DNS name of the service that we will
build to expose our database pod and
we'll see this in a minute
we can have multiple object definitions
inside the same UML file using those
three dashes
so this is our deployment object is the
same one that we have just created the
next one is the service and again the
same four parameters needs to be
provided the kind would be the service
the API version the name of the service
in the metadata and then our spec
definition and this is the key part here
which is a selector we we could use a
different label by the way we are using
the same label that we have on for the
replica set but we could have different
labels the object could have multiple a
any object could have multiple labels
attach it to it then in this case we are
just using the same label that we have
provided in the template definition
which is that one which is the key AB
and the value tasks AB then we have a
node port and the node there are
different types of the service and the
node port allows us to have a random
port and it's static across the nodes of
the worker nodes of the cluster and we
can connect to our service from the host
using that port and we see this in
action in the last part of the service
is the port section each service could
expose multiple services so if we have
multiple containers exposed from the pod
and those containers have different
ports we can use one service with
different ports to connect to them and
the ports have two parameters the port
that will this is the port that the
consume
inside the cluster could use to
communicate with the service and the
other port which is the target port
which is the one is living inside the
pod the next part is the deployment
object of the database it's similar to
the asp net deployment we have a
deployment object with the name mssql
deployment the number of replicas in
this case we'll just have one database
pod and then we have the selector which
is again using one label which is AB
mssql
and it's the same level that we have in
our template definition for the sequel
server pod and in the specs section we
have a new parameter that I have
provided here which is termination grace
period which is basically if we decided
to delete one of the pods kubernetes
will allow that pod to be gracefully
terminated within 10 seconds if it
didn't die within 10 seconds it will
force killing that pod and since this is
a database I just decided to give it a
few seconds to avoid having any
corruption with that the next part is
the containers and the name of the
container and the image I'm using a
sequel server image that runs on Linux
and it's actually provided by Microsoft
and again the image policy that I have
here is just use the image from my local
machine and the port which is the
default sequel server port and there are
two environment variables that are
required by this image as a password and
accepting the license the LA so so far
we have created the asp.net pod the
service sitting in front of the HP's net
pod the sick will deployment and finally
the service that will be sitting in
front of the service of the database pod
so it's similar to the one that we have
created for the edge with net bot the
only difference is a selector and the
port that this service is exposing so
let's deploy those four objects and see
them in action
I'll switch back to the dashboard we can
see that inside the deployment section
we have two deployments right now the
first one is for the sequel server
deployment and inside of it a replica
set and that replica set is with the pod
living inside of it and as you can see
there is a service already pointing to
that replica site or to the pods living
inside the replica set the the new
section that I wanted to show you here
is the services section and those are
the new services that we have created
and if we open we have two services the
sacred silver service and the asp.net
service opening the a spinet service we
can see that they are pointing to the
pods living inside our replica set and
if any of those pods died another one
will be created thanks to the replica
set but that new pod will automatically
be picked up by the service so you don't
need to keep a track of the new pods
this is done automatically by clip units
so if I just decided to deal delete or
kill that pod another one would be spend
up automatically and as you can see it's
automatically picked up by the service
right now the other part is the node
port part which is the random port I
think the default range for those ports
are thirty thousand to thirty two
thousand seven hundred something like
that and we can use that port to connect
to our service from the host machine so
I will grab the tasks port and then
we'll use localhost there you go we have
the application running right now the
only thing that we didn't see so far
which is the manage tasks part it should
be running but actually there is one
more thing that I didn't do which is
creating the database and the tables
that are required by our application
inside the database pod so for the
purpose of this demo I have created a
script to do that which is basically a
simple script to create a database and
table inside of it
it requires the server name and I will
provide the localhost and the port for
the database service
once this is completed our talks tab
should be running this one very good
right now we can see that the tasks has
been loaded and we can start adding
tasks to it which is great all right the
next thing that I wanted to show to you
is so far we managed it to deploy our
application or a spirit pod connect to a
secure server pod and if the database
pod died right now another one will be
spend up automatically but the data of
our cycle server is living inside the
container which means if the container
died for any reason we will lose the
data and since this is the data base we
kind of would like to maintain the data
regardless of the pot and to do this we
need to use another thing with inside
Copernicus which is persistent volumes
and persistent volumes allows us to
maintain a set of durable as a piece of
durable storage inside the cluster and
it captures the storage details the
kubernetes cluster has multiple storage
options that we can use it could be
either a local storage and network
storage or it could be even a
cloud-based storage and the persistent
volumes have individual life cycle from
the pods that could be consuming it and
any persistent volume could be
provisioned in a two ways the first one
is manually by the administrator or it
could be provisioned dynamically through
using another object which is the
persistent volume claim so the the
persistent William flame is basically a
request for us a persistent volume or a
request for a storage and that request
is basically you could provide I'd like
to request eight gigs of a storage and
there is another parameter that you need
to provide which is the access mode with
the access mode it's connected to the
storage mechanism that you're gonna use
and there are multiple access modes you
could have read write once read write
mini which the determining how many
nodes
how many worker nodes could connect and
consume your persistent volume and that
persistent volume could be consumed by
the pot as a data directory living
inside of it so if we deploy
our sequel silver application and as a
pod and we that put requested to have
eight gigs of storage
Copernicus cluster will automatically
provision the persistent volume for us
and once the persistent volume is
provisioned it will automatically
connect that volume to our pod to be
consumed by the containers living inside
the pod so let's see this in action I
will show you the public definition of
creating a persistent volume theme the
current deployment so here is our
persistent volume claim again the same
port parameters the kind is persistent
volume claim the API version to be used
by the cube City L the name was a
persistent volume claim the access mode
in this case readwrite once which means
my hosts and the resources and in this
case I just need eight gigs of storage
and as you can see I didn't the term or
didn't provide the cube in this cluster
with where that storage will actually be
is it the host or is it the network
storage or something each coupon each
cluster have a default storage class or
a storage type and since I'm using my
local cluster the default is using a
host path which is basically a directory
on the host machine you could provide a
different host or different storage
mechanisms using another parameter which
is called a storage storage class sorry
and you could have different storage
class names and those logic last names
disturbance should I use like Azure
storage or should I use a Google storage
or should I use network storage but for
the purpose of this demo I'll just keep
it simple and will use the host pass
that is living on my on my host machine
on my on my local machine now that we
have the persistent volume claim object
which is the request for a storage I can
consume that storage inside my database
pot so I have a new section here which
is called volumes and inside the volumes
we have a new volume which is mssql EP
and it's using the persistent volume
claim and all what we need to provide is
the claim name so this is the pot
section so we have added a pod added a
volume to our pod then we can consume
that volume inside our container and we
do this using the volume mounts inside
the volume mounts we provide the name of
the volume and the path width which
means if we are like building our using
this volume for our s treated
application or any kind of application
this will be the path that your
application is to use to actually write
the file into it and if you are like
writing c-sharp application you can use
the normal file IO classes to write to
the files to it such as like stream
reader or stream writer those will work
you don't have to use a custom or a
special API is to create read write
files inside the container so let's
deploy our object before I do that I'd
like to show you that the Electra that
this volume will be created inside of it
and this is basically since I'm using
docker for desktop this is going to be
inside the docker volumes directory so
right now it's empty once we deployed
our object eventually the persistent
volume will be created here and inside
of it the persistent volume clean if I
switch back to the dashboard there is a
section that allows us to view the
persistent volume claims so we have the
persistent volume claim created and it's
attached to our volume and here is the
volume also it's showing me the storage
class that I'm using for this persistent
volume claim and this is the default for
my local cluster in addition to that
it's showing me the location of that
persistent volume and if I connect our
application it's going to work fine and
I would like to show you if we went to
the database pot which is our sequel
server pod we can see that at the last
section here that there is a persistent
volume
that is being consumed by that pot and
if I deleted that pot for any random
reason that happened a new pot will be
is pinned up automatically and if I open
that pod we can see that it's already
attached it to the persistent William
claim object that we have created
because persistent we have created
decoupled the storage from the pot life
cycle and for all the demos that I have
been doing I want to show you that I'm
using a docker for desktop it's
basically if you are having a docker
installation already on your local
machine you go to the settings section
and in there you have a keeper unity
step and once you enable it this will
give you a coupon it is cluster on your
machine it has some limitations but it's
a very good start to start playing
around with coupon et's and see what are
the features and how would you accept
your with it but so far we have been
deploying coupon it is on my local
machine but at a certain point after you
build the application you would like to
deploy that application to a production
environment and you could do this by
provision capabilities in different ways
like on virtual machines on the cloud or
it could use cloud offering or even if
you have your own data center you can do
this as well but the I usually think
that there are there is a good value of
using platform as a service it might not
be the best case for all the situations
but one of the things that I believe in
is the platform of the service it makes
it very easy to provision a keep in each
cluster so we don't need to think about
how would we operate and maintain our
cluster as an example with the cloud
offerings for from Azure you don't even
need to think what's happening behind
the scene for your master node
they are already managing this for us we
don't need to think about how many nodes
we need how would we operate and pack up
and monitor those nodes it just happened
it happens for us moreover we could also
gain some features like those cloud
offerings allows us to update our
cluster to the latest version of
copernicus or change to a previous
version of communities without any
downtime of the HIPAA needs cluster we
could also scale the number of
worker worker nodes in our cluster
without any downtime and all those
features will take a lot of time from
engineering perspective to build
ourselves if we will use our own virtual
machines so and let me show you how
would you actually spin up a clip
Anita's cluster on top of Asia it's
pretty simple you just need one command
as your I guess this is the azure CLI
IKS is the azure capability service from
isis which is platform as a service
offering you provide create command and
provide the AKS cluster name and the
resource group name and behind the scene
in a few minutes you will have a keep a
fully functioning capabilities cluster
there are other parameters that you
could provide into your cluster creation
as well but I just kept it simple here
like the number of the worker nodes that
you would like to have and while you are
initiating by default I think there are
just three nodes after we create the
cluster we need to run another command
to access this cluster which is the get
credentials command and the get
credentials command responsibility is to
update that cube CTL client to point it
to the cluster that we just created and
this will allows us to use the exact
same commands that we have been using so
far which is actually like a couple of
commands but we don't have to have a
different version of the commands while
you are connecting through that to the
new newly created cluster so we can use
commands like get nodes or we could
apply or create or run anything that we
do on our local cluster will just work
on the new cluster and with just a
simple command we can spin up any
rescale the number of the worker node
that we have in the cluster it's just a
case a scale and this will automatically
change the number of the workers that we
have in the cluster even better with
cloud offerings like azor we could have
something like as a cluster autoscaler
and when we deploy the azure cluster
with a scaler what happens is it keeps
monitoring the work or the pods that are
scheduled on the workers and pasted on
the queue that we have from work on each
could start dynamically provisioned more
worker nodes or kill nodes and there are
some parameters or configurations that
we could provide to the auto cluster to
determine when and when to create or to
kill nodes and with this feature this
provides us with a better cost
management of our cluster because we
don't even need to worry how many
clusters we don't need to manually keep
interrupting our operation and
monitoring we don't have much
utilization of that worker node so let's
minimize the workers and stuff like that
and that's basically what I wanted to
share with you today what is that keeper
needs while you should care about it
what is the company's architecture how
would we use the key building blocks of
keeper needs to deploy our application
on top of it and what are the key values
of the cloud offering the I'd like to
share with you some resources so I'll
publish the presentation later today on
my blog if you would like to see the
demos that I have done today it's
already available on github you can
access it right now if you would like to
learn more about the spectrum of
hypnotists I would like to recommend
those two courses introduction to Cooper
needs and learning Kaepernick is using
interactive hands-on like with that
second part you don't even need to spin
up a cluster on your machine you can do
this in the cloud and the last part is
cue Benitez is moving very very fast so
if you would like to learn about any
subject in kubernetes I would recommend
to get back to the Corinthians
documentation because because this is
the almost always up-to-date source of
truth and that's what I wanted to share
with you today are not sure if I have
time for questions I think we have time
for a question or two
Tomic then the client when you connect
you Asia embeds that credential shoot a
good client so how do you switch between
the local and that's a very good
question so keep the cube CTL have
something called use DL config and with
the config I think I can show it very
quickly so cube CTL config this commands
has multiple sub commands that you can
use and I will show you cube sorry CTL
config get contexts this will show me
three this will show me the different
contexts that I have so on my machine
I have local for desktop mini cube and
NDC IKS cluster and I can use a command
like cube CTL config use context and the
use context will allow me to switch
between different clusters any other
questions
this wandering crew have video tests
that have all the environments like you
working Varma like this so we can just
do some experiment at home in Windows
humans so the question is - how would
you have multiple environments like the
Windows environment you set up for the
demo today how to set it up like we
could experiment how to do in a Windows
environments yeah this is actually our
Windows machine that oh yeah there's no
machine could you do how to set it up
like a step by step what kind of to to
install and yeah so first all what you
need is to go to the docker calm down
lose the docker latest stable one once
you install it you will have in the
settings section there is a tab for the
coupon it is and with that tab you just
this is by default will be disabled like
that once you enable it and you select
kubernetes apply this will automatically
configure your local machine with a
coupon it is cluster it will also
configure I believe the cube CTL to
automatically connect to that local
cluster this is not mini cube this is
just token for desktop and it has a
feature for the kunis cluster yep go
ahead
just managing your own cluster I
understand there are the cloud options
I've heard a lot of stories of the
cluster needing a lot of love keep it up
what's your take on that like how many
people would you dedicate to loving the
cluster as opposed to well so yes having
your own cluster it's similar to have
any kind of cluster that you have but I
think there are right now some good
solutions that makes it a little bit
better so if you would like to spin up
your cluster I think the way to go right
now is to use Cuba spray and this will
make your life a little bit easier when
you are spinning that cluster and if
you'd like to apply configurations from
infrastructure perspective the sequel
migrations
he used the sequel service node pole to
connect directly to the sequel database
yep would you still do that in object
well I think this will be actually a
case-by-case so I actually I think if
you will go with the kiparis cluster the
CI pipeline wouldn't actually you
wouldn't actually use those deployment
objects immediately you would usually go
with a helmet charts so helm is
basically allowing us to have a better
management of the queue penitas objects
so if you have multiple objects you can
package those objects in a helmet chart
and then you would use your helmet chart
in inside your CI pipeline but I don't
think if there is a specific object that
I have in mind that comes to the
database migration to use with coop
unities does that answer the question
yep
multiple services deployed and they have
to talk to each other
so how easy it is to manage using this
given it is so I think this is one of
the good offerings from communities so
there are if you're concerned about the
security there are some plugins that
could be attached to the Cooper nice
cluster to say this service could
communicate to that service or that pod
but it couldn't communicate to the other
put for any reason from a like
deployment perspective I would use
different I would consider each service
as its own application and it should
have its own the deployment or pipeline
because services should be independently
deployed and they should have different
lifecycle that's how would you iterate
on the micro services I think that's I
don't have time for more questions but
I'll be here for the rest of the day and
tomorrow so if you have any questions
please feel free to come and chat with
me thank you